Okay--the first tag we're going to learn about is the b tag.
And it looks like this: it's got an opening b and a closing b,
there's our closing slash.
And anything that appears inside the b tag appears bold.
So this is b for bold.
Pretty simple tag.
Let's play around with this in the HTML editor a little bit.
Here we are--we've got this--you know--
this plain text that we typed in before.
Let's make one of these words bold.
Okay--so I took the word love and I preceded it
by an opening tag and a closing tag,
and when we click update here, updates this
the word love is now in bold
pretty simple
quiz time - In the box below
make the words reasonably straight forward appear bold